as many of you know we've been taking
the real kind of systemic authoritarian
risk in the united states
much more seriously lately and when we
talked about the
possibility of a repeat in 2024 of what
the republican party under trump
attempted in 2020 it's no laughing
matter we also talked um earlier this
week about the warning from three
retired military generals that if you
had the
uh ranking
upper echelon of the military
supportive of something like what donald
trump tried to do in 2020 you could have
very different results because you could
have a military-involved coup in the
united states there is now another new
commentary from a canadian professor who
is warning that the united states could
actually fall to a right-wing
dictatorship by 2030. this is a very
interesting article not very long i
encourage you to read it we're going to
link to it and it says that a canadian
political science professor has warned
that the u.s could be under a right-wing
dictatorship by the end of the decade
this is thomas homer dixon founding
director of the cascade institute at
royal roads university in british
columbia
he is urging canada to safeguard itself
against the possible collapse of
american democracy he wrote in the globe
and mail by 2025 american democracy
could collapse causing extreme domestic
political instability including
widespread civil violence by 2030 if not
sooner the country could be governed by
a right-wing dictatorship much of the
professor's hypothesis centers around
the idea of trump returning to the white
house in 2024
trump is widely expected to run for
office again i don't know about that
i don't know about that
he's it's considered that he may and mr
homer dixon anticipates republican-held
state legislatures will refuse to accept
a democratic presidential win that is a
concern and we've talked about that so
many times now this idea that they
wanted to push on pence for january 6
2020 and we're almost at the one year
anniversary of that day the idea was
states that so i'll i'll break it down
from the beginning
before the election say you're worried
that there's going to be a lot of voter
fraud because of mail-in ballots
after the election when joe biden won a
bunch of these states they claim we
can't actually trust the results
and then the third part which they
didn't do they wanted mike pence to do
what they didn't do would have been mike
pence or whoever is vice president but
it was pens in 2020 at the time of the
certification of those electoral votes
of the acceptance of those electoral
votes rather the certification was on
december 14th or so january 6 was we're
going to tally these for pens to say
we don't believe that these are genuine
results so instead of allowing the
democratic electors from arizona to vote
we are going to seat an alternate slate
of electors to vote for trump that was
the idea
the concern now is they had the idea in
2020 but they didn't do it
that they're actually going to do it in
2024.
um
homer dixon is a well-respected scholar
of violent violent conflict
he says canada should be on guard
against the unfolding crisis in
washington dc spreading northward he
said quote a terrible storm is coming
from the south and canada is woefully
unprepared over the past year we've
turned our attention inward distracted
by the challenges of covid
reconciliation and the accelerating
effects of climate change but he says
now we must focus on the urgent problem
of what to do about the likely
unraveling of democracy in the u.s we
need to start by recognizing the
magnitude of the danger if trump is
re-elected even under the more
optimistic scenarios the economic and
political risks to our country will be
innumerable some might view such
warnings as hyperbolic but the political
scientist is steadfast in his view that
a new trump administration with little
in the way of internal opposition could
seek to deliberately undermine its
northern neighbor canada is worried
and we're worried about the same thing
and the crazy thing is that
we sort of just have to wait and see
what happens and what i mean by that is
trump was impeached twice not convicted
nothing really came of it
corruption in government isn't changing
for the better in any real way we got a
warning from three retired generals
yesterday that if the military were on
the side of what trump wanted to do they
might actually have been able to make it
happen and it could happen in 2024 and
unfortunately most americans don't even
realize what's going on
um i want to play for you this is really
interesting this is a clip from joe
rogan talking to jordan peterson and it
applies to this
they are talking about covet guidelines
this is the crazy thing they're talking
about covet guidelines
we're talking about actual
authoritarianism from a government
and even though what they are talking
about doesn't apply okay it this
actually does apply to what's going on
right now just don't understand how it
gets to them and actually they may not
even have been talking about covet here
they may have been talking about
it's not even clear what they're talking
about they're not talking about trumpism
and authoritarianism of that sense but
it would apply
things get to terrible places
one tiny step at a time you know if i
encroach i if i encroach on you and i'm
sophisticated about it i'm going to
encroach two millimeters i'm going to
encroach right to the point where you
stop start to protest then i'm going to
stop then i'm going to wait then you're
going to calm down then i'm going to
encroach again right to the point where
you protest then i'm going to stop then
i'm going to wait and i'm just going to
do that forever and before you know it
you're going to be back three miles from
where you started and you'll have done
it one step at a time and then you'll go
oh i understand
rogan this is i this is from a little
bit ago but rogan posted it yesterday
pretty obviously signaling that it's
about covid
but it applies perfectly to january 6th
the coup attempt and what we may be
facing get here and the answer was well
i pushed you a little farther than you
should have gone and you agreed and so
then i pushed you a little farther than
you should have gone again and you
agreed and if anybody's interested in
this sort of process and this is a
horrifying book if you want to read
about how this process works you can
read a book called ordinary men by
robert browning
so it perfectly perfectly perfectly
applies to what we are seeing now and
it's not
that people
necessarily accept
but it's that not enough is being done
to stop it from happening again and uh
relevant commentary from jordan peterson
not applied to what it should be applied
to